welcome to the brand-new drama behind
the scenes show I'm your host definition
and this is where we break down all the
backstage battles that happen in your
favorite movies this week the knives are
out in more ways than one with the
childsplay remake causing a lot of fuss
amongst fans Chucky has had a pretty
crazy career over the last couple of
years with each entry in the series
becoming more and more satirical but it
looks like child's play 2019 is causing
a lot of controversy for all the wrong
reasons the trouble this time comes with
the rights to the series being the main
root of the problem for those who don't
know child's play has always been a
franchise that like Chucky himself has
had a bit of a problem with ownership
the original film from 1988 was
distributed by United Artists however
the sequels were put out by Universal
who took over the franchise the
following year this is why we are seeing
a child's play TV show being pushed into
production that is completely detached
from this remake and is apparently
closer to the source material the second
big issue comes in the form of longtime
series writer Don Mancini who along with
the original cast has been tweeting out
some rather shade inducing things and
Cheney has been with the series through
all its ups and downs rises and falls
and it's understandable why the doll is
so close to his heart
man Cheney is currently involved with
the TV show and due to this he seems
like he's not that approving of the
recently released film while span Cheney
was originally offered an executive
producer credit for the new movie he was
also told that he would not be involved
and that this attachment to the film
would be in name only rumors are
currently circulating that man Cheney
was initially dismissive of the new form
that the doll takes which is an AI run
robot instead of a possessed piece of
plastic and this is why MGM wished to
kind of distance themselves in addition
to this Brad D refused voice Chucky
since the 80s was told that he would not
get to reprise his role with a studio
casting Mark Hamill as the character
late in production after the other voice
actors were not well received in tests
screen
Dieruff was understandably angry at
being cut from one of the parts that he
made into a massive success and recently
he tweeted out this image which reads
don't remake me or else which yeah the
guy doesn't look happy that Chucky is
getting a remake in addition to this man
Cheney has been pretty publicly angry
over the entire ordeal and in the
build-up to the movie's release he's
been urging fans to share pieces
slamming the film from The Hollywood
Reporter slash film also row an article
which said how am I supposed to feel
about child's play remake that man
Cheney himself declined to executive
produce to which man Cheney also shared
following this when the first image of
the new Chucky was posted and Cheney
tweeted out the following which shows
that he's not very approving of this new
take and is trying to distance himself
as much as possible the photo reads I
don't know her and the caption is this
is all I have to say on that subject
which pretty much sums up the entire
thing and Cheney later appeared on the
Mackerras post mortem podcast and said
the following obviously my feelings were
hurt I did create the character and
nurture the franchise for three decades
the studio just wanted our approval
which i strenuously denied them it's not
just a paycheck it's very personal and
MGM is screwing with her so obviously
he's not very happy with the entire
thing which i think is quite
understandable Chucky's basically is his
baby and he steered the franchise for
the past day yes
like imagine if you'd worked on a
project that long and someone took it
off you and decided to do something that
wasn't keeping with the true vision
you'd probably be angry as well there's
also a subtext to his interviews that
man Cheney is mad because his recently
written sequels were well received with
the last two being branded fresh on
Rotten Tomatoes
so I think in his head he doesn't really
see the need for a remake he is of
course head of the TV show - so this is
likely bound to cause conflict and will
probably have a few shots at the movie
in it overall I think it's quite
interesting to go through this stuff and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the drama and if you side with man
Cheney or if you think that it's okay
now for the studio to take the concept
and do something new with it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the script of midsummer which will be
linked at the end it covers the whole
movie so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more about the
film also let me know if you like this
new show every time some big drama comes
up around a movie's release I'm gonna
try and cover it so if you want to see
me break down bits of shades then make
sure you let me know this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]